hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream this is just a way
for all of us to stay in touch during
this time of school closures and as we
have in homeroom in the real world the
physical world which we all now really
miss it's a time for us to come together
to make announcements to answer
questions and that's what we want to do
here so as we go into the meat of this
homeroom conversation and it's really
just going to be a really informal
session today of being able to ask
myself and my team member Dan is going
to join us as well literally any
question so go onto Facebook going to
YouTube and ask anything you would like
of me or the team here at Khan Academy
what we have already been putting out
for all of y'all of parents teachers
students over the last several weeks is
based on the realization that Khan
Academy exists we never could have
foreseen this type of a situation but we
want to create structures and support so
that you can use all the content and all
the software that we've been making
which is all free it's all
non-commercial in a way that meets your
needs as a parent student or or a
teacher and so you can see right over
here these remote learning resources
we've been putting out things like
teacher webinars parent webinars lesson
daily schedules for students of
different ages also we put out learning
plans recently in math so the students
can learn through the end of the year
and through next summer so that or this
coming summer so they can not stop
learning I would do want to give a
special shout out to several corporate
partners who are helping support all of
this for many of y'all know Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit and with a mission
of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and that's
only possible through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself and
from some of our corporate partners that
you see listed here these are folks that
literally just stepped up in the last
few weeks they have we have other folks
who have been helping us keep going over
the last several years but we were
running at a deficit even going into
this situation and our deficit increase
because our traffic now is 2.5 actually
approaching 3x of what it typically is
we're trying to do more supports trying
to accelerate some content software
programs that we normally would have
done in a few years too so we can do it
sooner than later
Bank of America AT&T Novartis
org and fastly all organizations that
are really helping Khan Academy deliver
on its mission but with that I would
love to literally answer any question
you have and I'll issue a challenge to
surprise me and I have team members we
have team members who are looking at the
message boards on Khan Academy and they
are going to surface any questions and
Dan will also help me surface any
questions that folks might be having
let's see we have some questions I could
start while everyone's warming up with
some questions we had from last year so
from that from from last Friday that we
never got to the one person up there mom
chick Hassan from YouTube asks how come
Khan Academy is running a deficit and
what will that have an impact on the
provision of free world-class education
as you do now that's a very good
question Abdul Rahman so you know we're
running at a deficit because you know
simple math we're spending more than we
are bringing in in philanthropic
donations and we are able to do that in
the near term we do have a little bit of
reserves but obviously that's not
something that we're going to be able to
do indefinitely so what we've been the
reason why we've been spending more than
then the resources we've been bringing
in is the belief that these things need
to be out there they'll be able to serve
students parents and teachers that much
more and the hope that folks are going
to step up whether they're individual
donors or corporations or foundations to
allow us to do this work so you know
running a not-for-profit there's always
this tension of sometimes you want to
move ahead because you think some work
especially you know we're a bit of a
unique not-for-profit that we are we do
software and content we aren't your
traditional not-for-profit that you know
maybe does other types of great work
like running a soup kitchen or providing
malaria nets or things like that and so
a lot of our work has to be front-loaded
in terms of expense in terms of you know
we have approaching a hundred engineers
at Khan Academy we have designers
product managers we're all thinking a
year ahead two years ahead of what
to build and so sometimes we have to say
okay let's build it and hope we're going
to be able to support it but it's a
constant it's a constant tension that we
are we are trying to figure out but my
you know it's my intent that Khan
Academy hopefully doesn't disappear you
know when I do wake up in the middle of
the night that is my main concern I want
to ensure that Khan Academy is an
organization that doesn't just last
through my lifetime but has the
financial foundation that it can last
well beyond any of our lifetimes to
serve hopefully billions of folks in
generations to come but that is you're
hitting at a very real issue for for for
me and the team here so another question
so we have a great question from YouTube
from Selena Chang she says first hi Sal
hope you and your family are doing well
Selena's been engaging in online courses
at Khan Academy and meditation and her
question is what are some of the habits
that she can enforce to optimize
productivity and learning so take
anything something anything I have with
the grain of salt I'm always trying to
optimize my productivity and learning as
well but the things that I found are
definitely some form of structure helps
and it doesn't have to be and I actually
wouldn't make that structure too intense
I I think it's actually bad if you if
you're if your day is completely chopped
up into very small sections because then
you don't have time to do some deeper
things to do some more creative tasks so
what I try to do personally and I've
talked about this on the live stream
before is I try to have some easy wins
early in my day so I wake up I do that
meditation I you know get ready I make
the bed which I've talked a lot about
that gives you an easy win and then when
I in a normal time so I'm coming to the
office or I'm working from home during
quarantine I try to I find the morning
is when I get my most productive
creative work so that's why actually
when I try to do some videos so I try to
do two three four videos in that morning
time period and then I'm able to and
then I feel really productive and then
I'd try to go to the rest of the day if
I'm a student what I would try to do is
in that morning period I would try to
tackle the subjects that may be you you
you you you find take the most cognitive
load
for you and I would also make sure that
you have a little bit of time so you
know there's kind of this tension
between having fragments of time to make
sure you touch on everything and then
longer blocks of time so you can go
deeper I would try to ensure that you
get every day some amount of math every
day some amount of reading every day
some amount of writing and then free up
time in your afternoon for maybe if you
want to go deeper and say hey how far
can I get with this project or this
thing I'm trying to start other things I
would recommend is just remind yourself
to just get started it's easy to
paralyze yourself by overthinking things
but you say you know what let's let's
just let's just see what happens and
just put one foot in front of the other
and that act of moving will oftentimes
unblock you but we actually are hoping
to bring on some guests over the next
few weeks onto this live stream folks
who are experts in things like grit and
resilience folks even from the military
who are experts at things like
discipline and productivity and and how
to stay focused on things so we hope to
bring you more resources like that so
let's see from YouTube Katherine Pierce
asks how long does it take you to record
a video do you do anything to prepare or
do you wing it so great question
Katherine and the simple answer is it
depends you know this morning I got some
messages from Charlotte who's on our
content team say we need some new
content in some of our geometry because
we the were our old worked example
videos used the old exercises that we
had on Khan Academy now we have new
exercises so for something like that
where I'm able to take an exercise that
one of our team members has created copy
and paste it onto my little drawing
program that I have here that doesn't
take much at all and actually I try not
to over prepare for that so that when
the student sees me doing it it's really
in real time we're working through this
together I what we've heard and at least
what I feel is one of the benefits of
Khan Academy videos many of you all are
familiar with them they're not super
fancy in terms of you know computer
graphics or they don't look like a you
know help produced movie but their value
hopefully their differentiator is that
whoever's making the video with me or
someone else is really thinking through
it in real time they aren't reading a
script and so sometimes that leads you
know I might
pause I might say or something like that
but you can tell that we're doing it
together so something like a math worked
example not a lot of time and reasonably
winged so to speak but if I'm doing a
topic that I need a really refresh on or
go deeper than I might have even known
in before that could take some time you
know we have videos on Khan Academy in
world history or certain parts of say
organic chemistry that I definitely have
to spend several hours to research it
and then I what I oftentimes do is I
might write some just bullet point notes
just to make sure I hit the key ideas
but I don't write a script so the bullet
point you know might be like make sure
you don't misspell the steps of
photosynthesis or something like that
and then I start the video because I do
always want the student to the user to
feel that hey sounds really explaining
this his brain is really with his mouth
so to speak so hopefully hopefully
people get get that that feeling so
let's see from YouTube
Elliot H says and Elliot has been
referring to me as Dumbledore Sal which
I am flattered I think having scaled a
start up
do you envy friends who chose less risky
more lucrative careers in Business and
Finance does that grass ever seem
greener so Elliot you're asking a great
question that is a very deep and
philosophical question because as you
know grass often always looks deeper
looks greener on the other side but what
I found in my life is it's interesting
when I was in I guess you could say the
the more traditional industries back
when I was I used to work at a tech
startup and you know I I'm aging myself
you know 20 years ago now yeah I used to
work at some tech startups during the
first dot-com bubble then when I was
working at a hedge fund after business
school when I was that I and I was lucky
I always had very good bosses and I
always had I would say good jobs that
were intellectually stimulating I felt I
was compensated more than fairly but
there was that when you are measured by
if you're a hedge fund manager or hedge
fund analyst how much money are you
managing or what was the performance of
your fund or how large was your bonus
then when you measure yourself that way
it's very easy to you'll always find
someone
is managing a larger business who is who
has raised more money who's getting paid
more and that can and and y'all and you
also don't see how difficult their job
might have been you know I actually
really enjoyed my jobs maybe that friend
of mine from business school who was
making twice as much as me had a
horrible boss and had a lot of stress
and maybe you know their relationships
were breaking down so you never truly
see that side of it but it is tempting
to always say oh maybe I should be
making more maybe I'm making less and I
realized even before I started Khan
Academy that that's a never ending
proposition and a no-win proposition and
that was part of frankly the rationale
when starting Khan Academy to kind of
try to be in its own lane rather than
try to start it off as a business and
get and stay in that oh you know let me
let me beat those people out say no
what's the right thing for Humanity and
hopefully if we do the right thing
that's there for Humanity that humanity
or the world will help support this and
it's a very idealistic point of view but
you know we live once why not try to be
idealistic why not try to be optimistic
and I'll say you know I can only speak
for my own narrative it didn't come
without its share of stress and moments
that I thought I might have made a
blunder and and I'd wondered what it you
know what I was doing to my family's
finances and whatever that but when we
got that first funding and even though
you know my initial salaries at Khan
Academy back in the day were you know
it's a fourth or a fifth of what I was
making in the hedge fund world it it
didn't matter because I was still I
still had enough to be able to provide
for my family to eat out every now and
then to you know have our two Honda's in
a 2,000 square foot house and the fact
that I was able to spend my days doing
something that I really cared about that
I was able to get feedback from folks
around the world form a connection with
them feel like I was helping them that
made me feel like the luckiest person on
the planet and so you fast forward to
today no I I don't have any regrets and
if anything you know I obviously have a
lot of friends who've done very very
well in life you know I ask a lot of
them for donations now but I I don't
envy them in that way because I remind
myself that you know knock on wood my
you know I have my health my
family has their health you know I have
a amazing super intelligent beautiful
wife I have hilarious children I get to
spend time with them I get to work on
something that I care about and I'm you
know from my point of view the board
here at Khan Academy compensates me more
than fairly so I feel you know all my
basic needs for sure are met and so you
know what what else can someone ask for
is it's okay I think about it I I
actually I actually have trouble
thinking seeing other people's grasses
anywhere closest greenness as mice I
consider myself very fortunate so let's
see from Facebook
lotto stile off says how do you think
students can overcome their fear of math
so that is a great question and you know
you're talking about something that a
lot of adults very accomplished adults
were clearly very capable of so math I'm
afraid of that and my theory and I've
seen things that back up this theory I
saw this with my cousin's when I first
started tutoring them 15 years ago 16
years ago that the reason why they were
having trouble in math is math is very
cumulative and in a traditional model
you were pushed together at a fixed pace
and let's say that unit on dividing
decimals you're a little shaky on it you
got a 70 or 80% on a test
well that gap remains and then later in
9th grade in algebra class when you have
to divide decimals in that equation
you're like I never really fully learned
that this is stressing me out or maybe
you did learn it did not you forgot it
and so one of our core beliefs at Khan
Academy are we need to create the
mechanisms where you the student can
learn at their own pace
learn at your own time not have to feel
embarrassed about something if you're an
algebra student but you forgot how to
divide decimals not a big deal there's
many adults who provide decimals you can
go back to that content and not only get
videos but you can get that practice and
that feedback
so my answer lotto is especially if you
know you're a student and schools are
closed and you have the summer right
after that go to Khan Academy start at
the very beginning started early
learning on Khan Academy and I know that
stuff will seem super easy for you but
you'll be able to get through that if
you use the course challenges in the
unit tests literally in a matter of
probably less than an hour you could get
through early learning first grade
second grade and then just keep going
and
that strong foundation and what you're
gonna find is when you do that after a
few weeks you're going to get to your
grade level and when you get your grade
level with that strong foundation you're
like what was I stressed all about this
all makes sense now this is all
intuitive we get so many letters from 25
year olds 30 year olds 50 year olds 80
year olds saying I can't believe that I
used to be afraid of math I went on to
Khan Academy and I started learning from
the beginning and I realize how much fun
it is how it helps me look at the world
in a different way in a fun way and and
I realize that all those things I was
stressed about were because of my gaps
it had nothing to do with my ability it
had nothing to do with math somehow
being a difficult subject so that's
that's my that's my tip and my other tip
is that if you're going to do that do it
regularly I tell family members all the
time friends anyone who asked me put in
at least 20 minutes a day if you're able
to put in at least 20 minutes a day and
give yourself even a break on weekends
unless you're inspired to to take
advantage of the weekends as well but if
you do Monday through Friday 20 minutes
a day of Khan Academy always progressing
always trying to level up skills using
the course challenges unit tests to
accelerate as necessary get that mastery
I think in about a month you're going to
start having a different attitude
towards math and I would say in about
six months you're going to realize that
you're all of a sudden one of the
strongest math students you know so
let's see we have a question from
Facebook DD vant van wermer says do you
have any resources to make reading fun
so reading is an area that we are just
starting to get into it at Khan Academy
so it's a fairly nascent state we just
launched what's known as a beta and
software speak that's a early version
that still needs to be refined of
English and language arts
that's that starts at reading levels
roughly second grade through eighth
grade I will let you determine whether
it's fun I'll say the same thing that I
just told LOD about lotto about being
able to do things regularly if you are
an elementary student and reading is
something that you've always struggled
with start at the beginning put in
twenty minutes a day keep going with
that that could be helpful for older
students we have our official ICT
practice that has reading comprehension
in it and once again I think it's a
mindset you
when I used to prepare for standardized
tests when I was in school I disputed as
I said hey let me enjoy this thing it's
you know I'm kind of training for
something the same way that you would
train for for a sport so that could be
fun my other tip is try to find books
that you really enjoy and oftentimes
they'll be reading lists and we provide
reading lists too that will give you hey
here are books that are appropriate for
different grade levels etc definitely
take a look at those and have an open
mind to things but you know I discovered
my route love for reading when I started
to find books that were really about
topics that I found interesting when I
was young things like you know space and
the future I found captivating so I was
willing to push through books or maybe
even a little ahead of my reading level
because I was so captivated by that
thing so think about what what you're
interested in and then just keep reading
and I think that'll always serve you
well you know the more you read and the
more you're interested in it I wish I
could give you more more detailed
answers Sal would you like to take a
question on screen time we get a lot of
questions from parents about what the
amount of screen time so on Facebook
kübra shrivastava asks hi Sal hope you
and your family are safe and well and my
child enjoys learning on Khan Academy
and since the courses are so interesting
she can't stop doing them I wanted to
keep going but my concern is screen time
do I limit the lessons they're so fun
and interesting and should I keep that
should the app introduce time limits or
something like that yeah a great
question Shubra and one we get a lot and
so you know I don't know how old your
daughter is I mean it's a great thing
that she wants to keep learning my
general rule of thumb if she is younger
if she's if she's using Khan Academy
kids app and she's four or five years
old I would say you know try to keep
that screen time to you know limited to
sessions of 15 or 20 minutes and making
sure that she gets time outside time
with family plays gets creative time and
so I often type but you know I flipped
the screen time argument instead of
talking about well what's the right
amount of screen time I say well what's
the right amount of other things and so
you got to make sure that your child
gets time to play gets time outside has
quality time with with you and and other
family members and if they're able to do
that and they have time to
play and relax then I'm less worried
within some reasonable constraints on
the other hand there's kids who have no
screen time but the other on the other
side they're also not getting those
other things I would be far more worried
about those kids who are not running
around outside who are not getting that
meaningful time with their family but my
general rule of thumb for a very young
student I would say maybe 20-30 minutes
at a time max if if you know we're in
this kind of stay in place order world
with with Co vid I think all parents are
having to everyone it's going to have to
get on screens a little bit more than
normal even if it's to zoom or be on a
hangout with family members etc etc so I
would say use your judgement make sure
your daughter is able to play and has as
has time for true relaxation enjoy
outside of screen time for older
students you know there's a lot of
screen time where you know sometimes
when I'm when I'm making videos on Khan
Academy which is a creative activity I
might spend a few hours doing it or if
I'm writing a paper or if I am writing
some code and so if you have a 16 or 17
year old who wants to spend some time
practicing their calculus or their
history on Khan Academy or is writing a
paper or is wants to edit a video I I
would call that constructive screen time
and if an older student is there I would
still recommend that they get breaks
fairly regularly but if they can you
know that that could be several hours a
day but there I would still emphasize
make sure they have time to go outside
play have creative time and that if they
don't have to be on a screen they can do
things otherwise yesterday I saw him I
saw my son he my sister-in-law has been
kind of staying in place with us stay
and so she's she's in our house and he
wanted to play chess with her and he
like made her upload an app on her phone
so he could play on his iPad with her
and I was like this is ridiculous we
have a chess board go to the chess board
do not be on a screen just because it's
a screen and sometimes you know we all
are guilty of that sometimes or
something captivating about a screen so
I definitely think when possible go to
go to real life play real chess play
real Monopoly etc so let's see other
quest
I have here so Samira Hashem on Facebook
says can you provide guidance to more
people around the world to set up
learning centers like Khan labs we'd
love to see something like it in
Pakistan so Samira so for those who you
don't know there's a school called Khan
Lab School it's officially it's not part
of Khan Academy but it is a school that
I started along with several other
families six years ago that is that my
children go to and the whole idea there
is a lot of people think virtual
education is somehow in competition with
physical learning and I've always lost
the exact opposite that virtual things
like Khan Academy could be used to
liberate and empower what happens in a
physical setting that it could allow
students to do more games and
simulations and have Socratic dialogue
and time for play and so to prove I
wrote about that in the one world
schoolhouse and then to prove that out
said well there's no way better way to
prove it than to actually start a lab
school so that's what Khan lab schools
is our hope over time the school is now
K through 11 it's going to be K through
12 in a few months is that as we can
prove out this model more you know it's
also not for profit we just want to
share it with the whole world we want to
share what the model looks like and so
I'm hoping that in a few years anyone
who's interested in starting a school
like that could say okay this is what
they did out there in California here my
geography Pakistan wherever it might be
is a little bit different but I can
modify it to what we're doing in my
geography because I hope it can be an
example of what could be done either as
a new type of school or in traditional
schools extinct maybe we could run our
math class a little bit more like that
and we it's not that kind of logical has
it all figured out a lot of what is
happening at Khan Lab school is informed
by what's happening outside of it for
example Tim Vandenberg who we had on in
the daily livestream talking about how
he's had incredible results with his 6th
grade students in history in California
you know I
III forwarded that to the Khan lab
school teams like hey Tim's got some
great ideas we got to figure out how we
can how we can incorporate some of his
ideas a little bit better but thanks
thanks for asking so let's see other
questions so Kim heiling sorts and I'm
literally reading these without knowing
what
about to read out loud facebook says hi
Sal if you did not work with Khan
Academy what else would you be doing
what other projects are high on your
list of importance with regards to your
interest in skillsets
that's fascinating question who knows
what that alternate reality is I will
say that I'm it's it's perhaps in my
nature
obviously Khan Academy is where I focus
all my energies but there's parts of the
broader vision of Khan Academy around
how do you fully empower people how do
you empower teachers how do you empower
students how can you reach people who
might not have access to school how can
you give people credentials so they can
prove what they know so all of those
types of problems I'm fascinated by and
so I'm hoping that we can tackle most or
all of them within the umbrella of Khan
Academy but whenever I meet a friend who
has skills in a certain domain and
they're like hey what should I work I
was like well you should think about a
way to pair teachers and students or so
that they can they can you know it could
even be informal tutoring but you know
do in a way that can be free to empower
everyone or we should figure out a way
so that we can credential people so that
more people can get apprenticeships so
that whole area obviously is of interest
to me I would say if I wasn't working in
education the other area that's
interesting you know we talked about
meditation earlier I've become really
intrigued by you know happiness how does
someone become happy so much of our life
we measure by you know economic success
and Happiness at some level you do need
some base economics and you see that you
know it's it's a scary world we're
living in now or even in places like the
US or because of the the quarantine or
the closures a lot of people's economics
have gotten a lot tougher so you need
that baseline economics to have that
baseline of not being overstressed and
happy but then you see beyond that you
know things like wealth doesn't
necessarily correlate so much with
happiness so it's a fascinating thing
from from my point of view and you know
when I think about my children obviously
education matters I want them to be
proficient in math and reading and
writing and have a love for science and
and want to invent things but I also see
more and more and I see this with kids I
grew up with and family members that you
can be off
the charts academically but if you go
through you know life's gonna throw
stuff at you and you know I've been
fortunate I've been thrown a few things
but I know people who've been thrown
much much harder things and it's all how
you are able to process that and whether
you you know your level of resilience
and grit and all of that that really
determine where you end up so that's
actually a really fascinating space and
that's why we we experimented with a few
of these meditation videos for students
because that's kind of the intersection
about academic success but also
emotional resilience you know some of
these questions we're getting about how
do you overcome math anxiety it's
related to that same notion it's not
just about learning the quadratic
equation it's also about kind of
reprogramming your mind to realize that
you're fully capable of doing this
there's nothing wrong with getting a
question wrong that that's actually when
you learn the most and that you know no
matter what life throws at you
oftentimes you just have to wait it out
and it tends to get better than the the
the very dire situation that you often
find times find yourself obviously
there's exceptions there's people out
there dealing with war and hunger and
all of that but for all of us who aren't
dealing with war or hunger or bears
chasing us or you know really hard
things and there are people dealing with
disease and things but if you're dealing
with just day-to-day work stress life
stress education stress most of the
stresses abstract things in our mind and
and it's interesting to think about what
tools can we do to to make the best of
it so Kevin Rodriguez says Sal are you
playing around a new book read yours
years ago and loved it oh thanks thanks
Kevin
yes I I do hope I was actually planning
before all of this kovat stuff that
happened the book might be different now
the original thinking around the book
was trying to get a little bit more into
the space you know one world schoolhouse
which you know not to plug it but that
you brought up the book one world
schoolhouse was really about how did
Khan Academy exist what's the history of
k-12 education and then given where
we're going what and and what the
economy in the world is like what could
k-12 education be like in the future and
as I mentioned it was kind of the
inspiration for starting Khan Lab school
which can hopefully share things with
other schools to think about how things
could change then the next I do want to
think about is some of you know that's
signaling to the world how do
someone prove what they know to the
broader world what's the future of
higher education and and how does
someone showcase their best self and
also be happy about it so there is an
aspect of of social emotional well-being
above and beyond the academic that I've
been thinking about for the next book
and maybe it's the exact same book now
that this kovat thing happened maybe all
that stuff's even more important or
maybe you know because of kovat a lot of
things in the virtual space are having
to accelerate in certain dimension so
who knows when I when I get to writing
that that next book so let's see it
looks like we're we're all out of time
Wow laughter one more question since
since well there's actually a lot of
good questions if I whatever I don't get
today I'll get to in future sessions
when we don't have a guest but from
Facebook which Don the reek asks going
forward how important you think
traditional textbooks will be you know
I'm one of I I enjoy textbooks but I
think they are in a lot of wait you know
a lot of from my generation who did well
we were the subsets who were good at
reading textbooks we built that muscle
and I think there's always going to be a
skill there because there is so much
knowledge to be had in textbooks with
that said you know was a textbook
different than a nonfiction book a
textbook like a nonfiction book will
explain things to you but it also gives
you practice problems and my belief is
something like Khan Academy can give you
far more practice problems with far more
feedback and hopefully the explanations
we give either in video form text form
or even in the exercises when we give
the solutions that that's more
digestible than what would be in your
normal textbook so I hope that Khan
Academy can get a lot more people
learning at their own time and base and
I think textbooks will then become a
reference if someone wants to dig a
little bit deeper for some reason they
can't get online they always have that
reference set I think could be could be
really useful so I'm a little over time
this is fun time always goes by fast you
out though the questions are getting
better and better
but thanks for joining this is a fun way
to stay connected in times of social
isolation
I'll just remind everyone again we are
not-for-profit and we are only possible
we're
because of donations from folks like
yourself so think about that if you're
in a position to do so but with that I
will see you tomorrow have a good Monday
you